von das bayern-spiel und mein name ist
gesorgt karten sind auf die zunge und es
geht um den wettlauf 361 grad respekt
fantastische sache auf youtube ihr könnt
mit machen
könnte unter anderem einen auftritt in
unserer verschiedene oder an falcone
videos drehen und einschicken
wenn ihr also ganz großes glück habt
könnt ihr das gewinnen wenn er ein
bisschen weniger glückhaft da könnte er
beim interview mit einem promi dabei
sein und es ist natürlich eine andere
preise also seid kreativ kopf auf den
youtube kanal 361 grad hier unten in der
video beschreibung verlinkt und weil
gibt es auch neues habe ich auch der
song der heißt also in diesem sinne
lasst uns zusammen alle was bewegen